et ça nous a frappé sur la grille
extérieure de l'établissement avec un
bateau ça reste un déroulement dans le
dans l'appartement et ça me réveille à
chaque fois
[Musique]
la vie en commun se suppose le bruit le
bruit ça peut être sympathique c'est une
preuve d'animation de vie dans un
quartier mais le bruit ça peut
quelquefois être aussi insupportable et
si le problème ne se règle pas sur le
plan de la courtoisie il faudra alors
l'envisager sur le plan du droit
le chute de Fresnes privées dans une
cité quelles inconvénients résultent de
votre voisinage je suivais le dire de
nuit et deux jours par semaine sont
particulièrement prévues le mercredi et
les jeux et les dimanches étant donné
que les enfants sont en repos ainsi que
pendant la période des vacances
je me suis créé comme par exemple ils
font retourner leur mobylette dans la
cave de mon HLM je suis rez-de-chaussée
j'entends tout il s'amuse à frappé sur
la grille extérieure de l'établissement
avec un bateau ça résonne énormément
dans le dans l'appartement et ça me
réveille à chaque fois
ascenseur qui passe directement à
proximité de mon appartement il y a des
bruits tels que la benne ramassage de
poubelles
qui sont pratiquement insupportables on
ne peut pas tenir le coup je dors à un
bout de
[Applaudissements]
vous habitez les 400 maisons quel
problème vous pose vos voisins
le soir jusque 11
heures et après l'environnement dans la
voie qui est très bien entretenu et
quand on réclame aux enfants ou les
parents viennent nous insulter à notre
fenêtre parce qu'on les empêche de
détruire ce qui est bien dehors
mais vous-même avec notre machine est-ce
que vous gênez vos voisins je ne pense
pas je leur demande mais du fait que
c'est une ancienne construction les murs
sont assez épais et les bruits se
répercutent pas à l'intérieur des
maisons merci Madame
la
rue
le samedi
chercher des ardures dedans des yeux
cuir tout en tas de cochonneries et des
yeux bois qui ramène ici dans à d'autres
chez nous ces voitures sont pleins de
cochonnerie il nous ramène des bêtes
tout en tas de saletés
c'est tout
bonjour monsieur
monsieur Martinage est-ce que vous avez
à vous plaindre de vos voisins du bruit
en particulier
maintenant il fait froid ça se calme
mais
j'ai eu un moment je t'arrange
sont faits avec l'intention manifeste de
nuire à autrui on peut engager sa
responsabilité parce qu'on commet une
faute cette notion de relation normale
de voisinage est une notion extrêmement
floue qui varie suivant les cas qui
varient suivant la nature du bruit il
s'éteint dommage qui causé par un
particulier par exemple si vous habitez
à côté boulanger dans le four et la nuit
particulièrement bruyant vous irez
devant les tribunaux ordinaires qui
règlent les rapports entre particuliers
si au contraire le bruit excessif
provient d'une activité publique à ce
moment-là il pourrait être question
d'aller devant les tribunaux
administratifs monsieur Manet que
pensez-vous du bruit le problème du
actuellement vous savez il suffit
d'écouter on a le on a le autoroute à 20
mètres
le toboggan à 8-10 mètres à peu près
et encore vous êtes ici à une période
creuse de la journée faut venir à 6h du
soir à peu près on est obligé de fermer
les fenêtres on ne s'entend plus les
deux camions qui passent là
sur toute la journée et même une partie
de la nuit
l'autorité administrative aura un grand
rôle à jouer en interdisant certaines
sources de bruit par exemple en
interdisant les klaxons ou en imposant
des dispositifs appropriés aux engins
bruyants pour éviter les troubles qu'il
cause
le ministre vous êtes responsable de
l'habitat des Français c'est une lourde
responsabilité et j'ai vu que les
premières mesures que vous aviez prises
sont concernent le bruit dans les
logements et je crois que c'est un fléau
que vous avez décidé d'attaquer à sa
base oui nous n'avons pas décidé de
l'attaquer au hasard
nous nous sommes rendus compte que le
fait d'être logé plus au calme était une
des grandes aspirations des Français et
alors pour tous les logements qui ont
fait l'objet d'une demande de permis de
construire depuis le 1er juillet
1970 c'est une chose importante
on ne peut pas aller revenir au delà
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle c'est
évident
et bien
le fait pour les constructeurs de ne pas
respecter un certain nombre de normes
minimales
en matière d'acoustique donc de bruit
comme d'ailleurs en matière de sécurité
et dans d'autres domaines
et susceptible de leur valoir les plus
graves ennuis il s'agit pas de d'ouvrir
une chasse aux sorcières il s'agit pas
de dire que tous les constructeurs sont
des bandits il ne s'agit pas de les
désigner à la vindique publique car
quand nous engageons des procédures nous
ne livrerons pas le nom en pâture à
l'opinion publique ou à la presse mais
ce qui est important c'est que les
constructeurs sachent que nous ne
plaisanterons pas avec ce genre de
défaut et je suis certain que petit à
petit est très rapidement sans doute ils
font ils prendront une attention toute
spéciale à respecter le règlement de
construction sur ce point particulier de
l'acoustique comme sur celui de la
sécurité
je vous propose de regarder
[Musique]